It has been one of the most anticipated
announcements in the history of Las Vegas that
the largest sporting event in the country will
arrive at the stadium in just over 2
years that is greeted by Cristian
Cáceres in a unanimous decision the
National Football League announced Wednesday
that Las Vegas was the site for the super
little 58 after announcing the owner of the
beautiful said that it is a dream come
true for the city the game will
take place on February 11, 2024
the Metropolitan Police are looking for a man
who killed his  father before a house in the
eastern Las Vegas valley the incident
began as a entrenchment
that lasted several hours Police alerted neighbors to stay in their houses but
after several hours they found the
victim in the driveway of the house
near you  Huawei and Tropicana and
discovered that the son had
escaped
free from the state of Nevada together with
those from the neighboring state of Arizona and
California will invest in a project of
200  $0,000 to conserve water in the
next two years. The plan has the
main purpose of preventing the
water of Lake MIR from continuing to drop and they
plan to raise the water level by 16
feet at the foundation of the precious liquid that
will be used by more than a million
households per year the construction of
new houses increased by 8% in one year according to the
report of the Department of Commerce
Ribera, in addition to the fact that the construction of
new houses increased by 11%
last month at the national level, it is estimated
that more than one million will be built and
half a house a year some
restaurants in the Valley say they are in
trouble behind a shortage of a
popular ingredient cream cheese
we spoke with the owner of the Bego that he makes
and they told us that they have not been
able to buy cream cheese for weeks and they fear slowing down
the sales of his bakery  and bread
who plan to eat
cheesecake this holiday season the
factory company of the manufacturer of Philadelphia Cream Cheese
is offering $20 for
what  s who can't find the cheese to
make their desserts for details about
this promotion visit
the queen of rock and roll and the
golden girl are joining forces for the first
time on stage we talk about
Alejandra Guzmán and Paulina Rubio who
will launch a world tour and tell us  It is
one of the cities scheduled for
this for this concert, both will be
presented at the brooch stated on
May 21. Tickets go on sale this
coming Friday and we close with
the weather forecast as we can
see today we will have a sunny day
but with cold temperatures we will see
digits in the lows without accounts for
several days next week could
bring rain so don't put away the
umbrella I'm Cristian Castro after
suffering inflation news in Spanish
Buendía
[Music]